hey youtubers is Charlie so Walking Dead
finale is tonight so I thought it was
time to finally do a Daryl Dixon best
moments video just like it did for Rick
and Michonne so this is gonna be from
like season 1 to now there's so much
good Daryl Dixon stuff it's so hard to
pick like just like 10 Daryl Dixon
moments he is the best character that's
not in the comic books I would argue of
all the bigger cast members he's
probably the most popular next to Andrew
Lincoln there hasn't been as much of him
the second half of this season and I
think that the writers are putting Rick
forward as the main protagonist but I
think aside from that Daryl Dixon is the
biggest character or at least the most
fun one next to Carol and whenever those
two get together they just push Rick
like right off the screen it's like it's
not even there seriously can you even
imagine someone else playing Daryl Dixon
like what if Michael Rooker and Norman
Reedus like swapped roles I don't think
that would work it would be terrible
they were both born to play their roles
like Michael Rooker is the preeminent
[ __ ] he is so great at playing that
dirtbag Burrell and Norman Reedus is the
perfect outdoor cat that thinks he's an
indoor cat just a real quick reminder to
there's a double rounded they gave away
starting whenever I post my finale video
tonight up to the episode airs so let's
get started just careful for spoilers
for everything through season 5 on the
show so far starting in chronological
order so we're like in season 1 right
now Daryl saves t-dog twice in a row
this is just like a really great save
tdawg you know who definitely looks like
he does not belong in this world this
post-apocalyptic world gets safe from
Daryl buy this Walker that's coming up
on him Daryl puts his crossbow down then
quietly comes up behind the Walker
knifes it sets it on top of t-dog and
then quietly goes Yanks another Walker
out of a car kills it and lays it on top
of himself so that they can disguise
themselves from this pack that's coming
up on him it was super leet and kind of
funny at the same time and I feel like
all the best Daryl moments have a little
bit of comedy and a little bit of horror
in them although I guess you could say
that for most The Walking Dead onto
number 9
Daryl kills the Walker bride inside the
church this just reminded me of the
first half of season 5 with the hunters
when they went into the church very
similar type of set it's funny to see
how little Carl was Andrew Lincoln
actually he called him an Ewok when they
first started the show daryl is so funny
though when he hatchets this Walker
bride in the face like it turns around
and he just flips his [ __ ]
you could look at that as a metaphor for
how he feels about getting married
although I do think his relationship
with Carol right now on the show is as
close as you could get to being married
without actually being married even
though their relationship is
unconsummated we can let tumblr correct
that Grievous error moving on to number
eight daryl wakes up on the river bed
with a crossbow bolt in him and a walker
chewing on his foot this is a great WTF
wake up scene daryl ends up fighting
them off you know bashes the walkers
skull in this really brutal way then
Yanks the crossbow bolt out of his leg
and uses it to kill another Walker
that's coming up on him there were
enough walkers to provide him with some
nice additions to his walker ear
necklace too which is just one of the
most awesomely disgusting props that he
ever had on the show on to number 7
moving into like the second half of
season 2 daryl tortures randall this is
one of those moments where daryl good
character does something really awful to
an awful person it's kind of like what's
going on with porch dick and Rick right
now maybe not quite actually it'd be
more like Rick torturing the governor
for information it's like you take the
character to this really dark place
because they're trying to do something
good being awful in the name of being
good that's kind of where Rick is right
now just in general on to number 6
moving into season 3 stuff
Daryl goes apeshit when they start
clearing the prison out for the first
time this is also on my Rick Grimes
moment list it was basically like a
video game
montage of Walker kills I think the only
Daryl montage kill scene that topped
this for me was during the mid-season
finale in season 4 just plain and simple
Daryl freeing the beast all over the
prison onto number 5 Daryl vs. Merle
battle to the death so the governor made
them fight to the death and they have
this big battle royale it's like
Thunderdome Walking Dead edition two men
enter one man leave although technically
in this case they both left this is
before Merle got sympathetic again like
they had just found him he was still in
full-blown Merle [ __ ] mode Daryl was
on like a reverse Merle arc where it's
like Merle gets darker and darker and
Daryl gets nicer and nicer as the series
goes on it was just a beautiful
knock-down drag-out fight between two
brothers I've had childhood fights with
my brother none quite so bad as that
none of us had blades for hands on to
number four Daryl kills Walker
Merl this is like the end of season 3 I
would say 90% of the Daryl Dixon memes
on the internet right now come from this
Daryl reaction shot one of the most
emotional daryl scenes from the entire
series but he sees his brother and it
just is horrified one of the saddest
Daryl moments ever next to him watching
Beth die the funny thing about what
preceded this is is this like this Merle
scene eating been is very poetic because
earlier Merle tried to assassinate the
governor been accidentally got in the
way of the bullet so he killed Ben so I
guess you could view Walker Merle eating
Ben has been spun --is-- meant for
accidentally allowing the governor to
continue to exist wants number three
Darryl in the survivors versus the
governor's people during the mid season
4 finale like I said earlier this is
like my favorite Daryl Dixon montage
Walker kill scene although there were a
bunch of the governor's men inside that
montage Walker shield probably the best
use of a walker in battle although I
will say Daryl during the mid season 5
finale when he ripped the Walker head
off and bashed another Walker with it
using a walker head as a weapon
you know ties this really kind of funny
montage with him using the Walker shield
never forget walkers make really awesome
weapons too
just as long as you like separate their
head from their body slam dunk grenade
also really sweet too let's say of all
the characters they get really awesome
kills Michonne obviously with her katana
gets a lot of really badass fight scenes
Daryl though is one of the best at using
improvised weapons now they have Abraham
Abraham's kana in that same vein - he's
kind of a military man so he's used to
it but I think there's a little more
grace to Daryl style using improvised
weapons there's just a little more
finesse than Abraham's technique on to
number 2
Daryl and Beth solo field trip during
the second half of season 4 there was a
lot of great WTF you know action scenes
but we really get it's like a deep dive
into Daryl's psyche the funny thing is
is that Beth Neri it's most of the
episode like Daryl's not a big talker so
Beth is the one that does most of the
talking eventually we find out a little
bit about his childhood Beth ends up
helping him burn down the cabin that
represents his childhood the other
really cool way to look at this is that
you know obviously Daryl is teaching her
how to survive teaching her to use
weapons like the crossbow that's really
cool so it's kind of like senpai Daryl
but she's also teaching him how to be a
human being so it's kind
like senpai Beth and finally my number
one Daryl Dixon moment Daryl in Carol's
solo field trip during the first half of
season 5 although I guess you could say
all choice Daryl rebuilding the
motorcycle in the second half of season
5 it's really hard to pick like a number
1 Daryl moment because we haven't seen
the finale yet so just keep in mind that
this has none of the finale moments in
it any scene with Carol and Daryl is
always gonna be a lot of fun but their
trip to go find Beth to infiltrate
Atlanta and find out about the hospital
probably my second favorite side episode
next to Beth and Daryl I feel like those
two episodes really show you what it's
like to be a survivor of abuse the
difference is is that in the the Beth
episode the best solo episode with him
you learn about Daryl's history of abuse
in the Carroll Daryl episode you'll
learn about Carol's history of abuse to
be fair though Daryl was the one that
took that book about learning to cope
with abuse it's just so much fun to see
what daryl picks up from other people
that he travels with I think he learned
more from Beth and Carol than from
anyone else than from Merle or anyone
else he has the skills to survive you
know he's like one of those characters
who benefited from the apocalypse like
he's more suited to survive in the world
of the apocalypse than he was suited to
survive in more civilized society like
he just wasn't made for the real world
so I think that's why people are getting
really nervous about what might happen
to him in this season finale because
they kind of are back in civilized
society inside this Alexandria safe zone
place not that anyone thinks that's
gonna last forever there is no place the
survivors will go that will not be
overrun by walkers within six months
here's my big question for you guys
though you know what's your favorite
Daryl Dixon moment and if he had to die
like whichever episode that might come
in how do you want him to go out I'd say
if he ever went out I'd like it to be
saving someone else like saving Carol's
life I think that'd be a really noble
way to go out then you could have like a
Carroll moment where she says claimed
and just like kills whoever killed Daryl
just like BAM went to one right out to
the other that's really what I want I
want like a Walking Dead survivor
claimed montage and by the way when
Daryl finally does die I totally claim
that motorcycle somebody else can claim
the crossbow so just a quick reminder
Walking Dead finale tonight be sure to
subscribe to get my video gonna be full
of so many WTF I'll do a top 10 video
just like I did for the season 4 finale
it'll be a double giveaway - so I'll
explain that whenever I post that video
also really important during the finale
they're gonna air the first trailer for
the spin-off show fear The Walking Dead
so I'll do a separate video breakdown of
that because the trailer is probably
gonna be pretty short I'll probably post
that video first and then I'll post my
finale review while you guys wait for
that to drop you can click here for my
latest Game of Thrones Season 5 video
and you can click here for all my
Walking Dead Season 5 videos thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight now I claim all your high fives